monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres chers collègues enfin nous y
voilà
c'est la fin de ce marathon nous voilà
parvenus au terme de cette course
législative à cet instant que nous
croyons il y a quelques jours encore
inaccessibles nous voilà parvenus à cet
acte le vote qui fonde la légitimité du
Parlement notre raison d'être et je le
pense aussi notre honneur et pourtant
chers collègues de gauche vous avez tout
fait pour empêcher cet acte fondamental
par l'obstruction par l'obstruction plus
de 8000 amendements et de sous
amendements des rappels au règlement en
veux-tu en voilà vous avez été recherché
dans notre règlement toutes les
techniques qui permettaient d'empêcher
d'empêcher le vote vous étiez mauvais
perdant puisque vous aviez par avance
anticipé votre défaite et c'est la
raison pour laquelle vous vouliez
empêcher le vote mais nous y voilà et ce
vote sera pour nous déjà une victoire
mes chers collègues mes chers collègues
cette obstruction
vous a permis d'entendre énormément de
prises de parole de nos collègues de
gauche sans que on sache bien qu'elle
s'était vos propositions vos solutions
le Yaka faucon oui le yakafocon oui
souvent mais que faites-vous pour faire
face
à ce grand choc que la France va devoir
dans les prochaines années affronter
l'autre choc il y a bien sûr le choc
climatique mais il y a aussi le choc
démographique du vieillissement les
départs en retraite vont être multipliés
par 4 par 5 que faisons-nous que
voulez-vous faire nous nous agissons
nous avons voulu agir et cette réforme
nous l'avons voulu monsieur le ministre
messieurs les ministres mais Monsieur le
Ministre du socle tout particulièrement
je voudrais m'adresser à vous
vous irez porter ce message au président
de la République c'est très fort nous
allons la voter mais nous ne doit-on pas
pour lui c'est très forte nous la votons
parce que c'est notre réforme c'est ici
qu'elle est née nous la voterons parce
que nous l'avons modifié ces notes que
nous allons voter la surcotte pour les
maires de famille
les orphelins handicapés la lutte contre
la fraude
l'emploi des seniors qui sont souvent
trop souvent à l'âge de 57 ou de 58 ans
au chômage les questions de la
pénibilité de l'usure professionnelle ce
sont ces ajouts que nous avons voulu
apporter à ce texte là si nous votons
cette réforme ce n'est pas parce que le
gouvernement d'Emmanuel Macron la
propose dans c'est pour l'intérêt
national
parce que nous voulons sauvegarder un
régime de retraite par répartition j'ai
entendu les moqueries sur les questions
de chiffres et d'équilibre non ceux qui
se moquent des chiffres se moquent des
français derrière les chiffres il y a
des déficits derrière les déficits il y
a l'argent des Français et derrière
l'argent des Français il y a la peine
des Français
le régime
pas répartition que nous soutenons c'est
celui qu'il faut sauver parce que demain
sinon il y aura un effondrement du
pouvoir d'achat de nos aînés et nos
jeunes devront payer deux fois la
retraite notre votre retraite et leur
propre retraite c'est cela que nous
voulons évidemment préserver comme nous
voulons préserver la croissance de
demain qui est le chemin de la
prospérité et derrière cette réforme il
y a le taux d'emploi il y a cette
capacité que nous aurons de mettre
encore plus de travail dans l'économie
française nous sommes le dernier un des
derniers pays européens par la quantité
de travail et c'est la pauvrissement
assurée si nous en restons là nous
voulons ce chemin de croissance chemin
de prospérité vous voulez la
décroissance le déclassement et la
pauvrissement mais au-delà de ces
considérations
matériel ne nous battons pour quelque
chose de beaucoup plus essentiel que les
retraites ou la croissance nous nous
battons aussi pour des conditions
immatérielles nous nous battons parce
que derrière cette réforme derrière ce
régime intergesse générationnel il y a
un lien il y a ce lien entre les
générations qu'expriment le régime par
répartition et c'est ce lien qui nous
manque tant en France dans une France
archipelisée morcelée fracturé qui
matérialise que nous sommes un peuple
une seule communauté nationale voilà
pourquoi nous allons monsieur le
ministre mesdames Messieurs mes chers
collègues la voté et je terminerai par
des remerciements remerciements d'abord
aux rapporteur au rapporteur à la
rapporteur général qui a fait preuve
d'une grande combativité
remerciement à notre rapporteur à notre
rapporteur René Paul Sabari avec son
énorme travail
avec sa zénitude même sous les attaques
de la gauche bravo chers collègues à
notre président de commission
notre président de commission dont la
voix au perché se transforme parfois en
lames coupantes et certains le savent
ici et en ont fait les frais merci à
tous les trois je voudrais aussi
remercier nos collègues qui ont été
présents regardez cette présence encore
merci mes chers collègues d'avoir enduré
des séances
qui n'apportait souvent rien aucune
solution
mais où il fallait refaire face aux
manœuvres d'obstruction des oppositions
merci mes chers collègues monsieur le
Président enfin